isolierung von erkrankten und die
nachverfolgung von kontakten
die quarantäne von kontakten der
kategorie eins die gezielte testung von
erkrankten und von kontaktpersonen das
heißt diese strategie die maßgeblich
auch darauf beruht dass die
gesundheitsämter gestärkt werden muss
weiter gefahren werden ist wichtig und
bleibt auch noch viele wochen wichtig
der zweite säule ist der schutz der
besonders gefährdeten gruppen das sind
die chronisch kranken und das sind die
alten und hochaltrigen menschen auch
hier muss weiterhin dafür gesorgt werden
dass diese personengruppen vor
ansteckung geschützt werden und die
dritte säule unserer strategie zur
bekämpfung der cholera-epidemie in
unserem land ist es die
versorgungskapazitäten zu erhöhen also
hier steht im mittelpunkt dass die
intensiv und beratungskapazitäten in den
deutschen krankenhäusern erhöht werden
müssen und die kliniken und ambulanten
praxen müssen so strukturiert werden
dass patienten gezielt zugeführt werden
das heißt es geht hier um strategische
maßnahmen damit wir so viel wie möglich
menschenleben retten können in dieser
epidemie nun zur lage-einschätzung
zuerst weltweit ein kurzer überblick das
ist der stand 30 dritter 10 uhr und das
sind daten die wir vom europäischen
zentrum für krankheitskontrolle cdc
erhalten haben stand wie gesagt 30
dritter 10 uhr
dort hatten wir und deutschland ist bei
diesen berechnungen nicht in enthalten
weltweit 658.000 fälle rund
das waren zum vortag insgesamt fast 450
1000 fälle mehr
darunter fanden sich 33.000 124
verstorbene das ist ein anteil an den
gemeldeten fällen also eine sterberate
von fünf prozent in der europäischen
union europäischer wirtschaftsraum wozu
auch das vereinigte königreich hier noch
gezählt wird haben wir insgesamt 300
1804 fälle und das ist eine differenz
zum vortag von port +23 1229 fällen
insgesamt sind in dieser region bislang
offiziell gemeldet 23.000 sechs menschen
fest
das ist eine anteil von verstorbenen von
7,6 prozent das heißt diese epidemie
diese pandemie läuft weiter und sie wird
noch einige wochen unterwegs sein und
monate schauen wir uns ganz kurz ein
paar länder an nur um in ein eindruck zu
geben
italien hatten wir zum gestrigen
zeitpunkt 10 uhr annähernd 98.000 fälle
in spanien annähernd 79 1000 fälle und
in frankreich mehr als 40.000 fälle
vielleicht noch einen blick nach westen
in die vereinigten staaten
hier wurden gemeldet offiziell gestern
153.000 25 fälle von kogit 19
das war eine differenz zum vortag von
mehr als 18.000 fällen in den
vereinigten staaten ist nach diesen
berechnungen aktuell eine sterberate von
1,8 prozent
zur zeit gegeben im iran sind offiziell
gemeldet bislang rund 38.000 fälle
und dort ist die sterberate gestern um
10 uhr mit 6,9 prozent berechnet uhr
kommen wir zu deutschland wie sieht die
situation in deutschland aus und hier
ist der stand der 31 30 uhr in
deutschland wurden also bis heute zum 31
30 uhr insgesamt 61 1913 cupid fälle
elektronisch übermittelt von den
gesundheitsämtern an das robert koch
institut
das sind 4615 fälle mehr als am vortag
das heißt also die fallzahlen steigen
weiterhin über das auch erwarten
zu dem zeitpunkt waren offiziell
gemeldet 583 todesfälle in deutschland
ich werde gleich die todesfälle noch ein
wenig mehr differenzieren
das waren 128 fälle mehr als am vortag
für uns epidemiologen ist die gesamt
incidents wichtig das sind die fälle pro
100.000 1
auch die steigt die war zu dem zeitpunkt
74 fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
so wie ich das auch ihn mehrfach schon
erläutert habe gibt es immer wieder
regionale unterschiede das ist auch ganz
normal
wir müssen die hat canon um die
maßnahmen zu bewerten
so ist in hamburg zum beispiel zu dem
zeitpunkt heute 0 uhr die inzidenz bei
119 fällen pro 100.000 und in
mecklenburg vorpommern liegt sie
momentan bei 23 fällen pro 100.000 also
regionale unterschiede die wir immer im
blick haben müssen eine gute nachricht
nach unseren schätzungen die wir
konservativ durchführen nach unseren
schätzungen sind zu diesem zeitpunkt
also 33 30 uhr 16.100 menschen auch
bereits genesen
die mit kuwait 19 erkrankt waren schauen
wir uns die fälle in deutschland etwas
genauer an
die betroffenen personen sind im
durchschnitt also fälle die erkrankt und
gemeldete fälle vom gesundheitsamt die
betroffene person sind im durchschnitt
47 jahre alt 52 prozent sind männer also
leicht mehr männer als frauen und von
den fälligen genannt ablegen und für
rund 41.000 klinische informationen vor
dass heißt dort haben die
gesundheitsämter die informationen in
das meldesystem das elektronische
meldesystem eingetragen nach wie vor
steht husten mit 43 prozent und fiebere
mit 41% im vordergrund das heißt wir
erfassen eben in dem meldesystem auch
viele leichte fälle
das liegt daran dass wir sehr viel und
früh getestet haben und weiterhin testen
nun zu den todesfällen in deutschland
ich sagte ihnen das bislang nachgewiesen
583 personen im zusammenhang mit der
komik 19 erkrankung verstorben sind
die personen waren im durchschnitt 80
jahre alt unter den verstorbenen waren
506 personen das sind 87 prozent 70
jahre und älter
die jüngste verstorbene person war 28
jahre alt und sie litt an vor erkrankt
noch mal wichtig das was wir ja seit
anfang betonen
jede person unabhängig von der
altersgruppe kann an cupid 19 erkranken
aber das risiko schwer zu erkranken
steigt mit zunehmendem alter und es
steigt auch damit obmann vorerkrankung
hat oder nicht aber prinzipiell kann
wirklich jeder altersgruppe infiziert
werden
das zeigt auch die statistik der
altersgruppen jünger als 60 wird von den
verstorbenen jünger als 60 jahre waren
insgesamt 31 personen davon 26 männer
und fünf frauen zwischen 60 und 69
jahren unter den verstorbenen waren
insgesamt 44 personen 32 männlich 12
weiblich
in der altersgruppe zwischen 70 und 79
insgesamt 130 personen davon 102 männer
und 28 frauen und in der gruppe
altersgruppe 80 bis 89 185 männliche
personen und 120 weibliche personen und
bei der gruppe 90 jahre und älter sind
38 männliche und 33 weibliche person das
ist die aktuelle angabe über die
verstorbenen an cupid 19
heute mitternacht 00 uhr das ist die
nüchterne lagebeschreibung lassen sie
mich noch einige informationen geben was
wir alles tun was in deutschland viele
menschen tun um diese drei säulen die
ich am anfang nannte wirklich optimal
nutzen zu können stärken zu können
ein wichtiger punkt ist das sogenannte
die wie intensiv register das hatte ich
ihnen bereits vorgestellt das ist eine
initiative der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin des robert
koch instituts und der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft
was ist der sinn dieses gw intensiv
registers es ist eine website über die
freie beatmungs plätze in allen kliniken
deutschland trinkt ist
und abgefragt werden können ich glaube
sie können sich das sehr gut vorstellen
wenn immer mehr personen beatmet werden
müssen dann ist es natürlich sehr
wichtig dass die rettungsdienste diese
personen auch zielgerichtet in
krankenhäuser bringt wo noch heuer
beatmungs plätze vorhanden sind
das heißt diese intensivmedizinische
kapazität für die schweren
krankheitsverläufe ist definitiv ein
schlüsselelement in der bewältigung des
kit 19 ausbruchs und darum ein ganz
zentraler teil der dritten säule unserer
strategie zur bekämpfung und ich möchte
an dieser stelle nochmal allen danken
die daran mitgemacht haben dieses
register ist ein großer erfolg der
anteil der teilnehmenden kliniken liegt
aktuell bei 729 von ca 1116
intensivbetten führenden kliniken in
deutschland
das sind also circa 63 prozent das ist
der stand von gestern
ich möchte noch mal alle kliniken
auffordern ganz intensiv und nachhaltig
nachdrücklich auch noch mal auffordern
dass wirklich alle kliniken in diesem
register melden denn eine optimale
zuteilung von freien kapazitäten
natürlich auch überregional wird nur
möglich sein wenn wirklich alle
relevanten kranken ob sie sich
beteiligen aber nochmal das ist ein
großer erfolg
toll dass das möglich ist bitte machen
alle kliniken damit damit wir optimal
patienten versorgen können da möchte
ihnen kurzen einblick geben eine studie
die initiiert wurde von cornelia betsch
professor cornelia bild von der
universität erfurt
an dieser studie ist das
robert-koch-institut von anfang an
beteiligt gewesen und auch weitere
partner die studie heißt cosmo nach
dieser studie haben wir folgende
folgende ergebnisse das heißt wie wie
geht es wie gehen die deutschen mit
dieser herausforderung um wie ist die
risikowahrnehmung wo ist das wissen
unsere deutschen mitbürger das ist eine
gute studie die sie auch im internet
verfolgen können in der in der letzten
befragung aller letzte woche waren ein
und 41 prozent der deutschen der
befragten halten die kurve 19 erkrankung
für gefährlich und ein knappes drittel
ist sich unsicher wie gefährlich die
krankheit
das heißt gegenüber der vorwoche da
waren nur 34 prozent der mitbürger davon
überzeugt dass eine gefährliche
krankheit ist es ist eine gefährliche
krankheit und je mehr menschen das
einsehen und begreifen desto besser
werden sich natürlich auch verhalten und
sich selber und auch die anderen vor der
krankheit schützen
es zeigt sich dass ältere und chronisch
kranke menschen eher als junge und
gesunde denken dass die erkrankung für
sie schwerwiegend wäre das ist auch
korrekt wer im gesundheitssektor
arbeitet oder angst hat hält der
erkrankung für schwerwiegender als der
durchschnitt das heißt es ist wirklich
wichtig dass alle menschen verstehen
dass es sich um eine schwerwiegende
erkrankung handelt und es ist gut dass
wir einen trend sehen in deutschland
dass dies auch der fall ist denn damit
verbunden ist ja dann auch das wirklich
mehr vorsichtsmaßnahmen getroffen werden
beziehungsweise die maßnahmen die
angeordnet werden auch durchgehalten
werden
das aus was geschehen wird insgesamt von
vielen immer noch eher als ein
medienhype wahrgenommen
die tendenz sinkt allerdings
kontinuierlich weil die ausbau situation
als medien halb wahrnimmt bewertet das
risiko natürlich auch geringer das ist
bedauerlich ich möchte wirklich alle
menschen bitten diese krankheit ernst zu
nehmen und sichern das abstandsgebot und
dass wir bleiben zu hause halten das ist
die wichtigste maßnahme
wir können das virus wird hauptsächlich
übertragen durch tröpfcheninfektion also
husten und niesen und darum ist abstand
halten und die nis und husten hygiene
also in den armbeuge niesen und husten
wirklich sehr sehr wichtig wir stellen
auch fest dass ältere immer noch eine
geringere erkrankungswahrscheinlichkeit
wahrnehmen
sie betreuen oft die enkelkinder wegen
der schließung von einrichtungen
allerdings weniger als in der
vergangenen woche und sie fühlen sich
psychisch widerstandsfähiger und weniger
belastet und sie zeigen dadurch
eventuell auch weniger schutzverhalten
das ist großartig dass die älteren
diesen dienst übernehmen aber ich möchte
sie wirklich alle nochmals sehr
nachdrücklich auffordern zu verstehen
dass sie sich alle gegenseitig schützen
müssen
ältere können jüngere anstecken und
jüngere können
strahlenschutz anstecken das heißt also
wirklich bitte achten sie darauf auf
dieses risiko und ich bitte die sich
alle so gut wie möglich zu schützen
und hier auch ihr schutz verhalten
anzupassen
ein weiterer aspekt dieser befragung ist
der die korrelationen zwischen einem
gefüllten wissen über das richtige
schutzverhalten und den tatsächlich
ergriffen schutzverhalten bleibt
weiterhin leider gering bis mittel das
heißt also rund 90 prozent wissen dass
sie zu hause bleiben sollen das ist ja
eine der forderungen in der die wir
haben wenn sie krank sind aber lediglich
77 prozent tun es auch hier wieder meine
aufforderung wer krank ist und zur
arbeit geht der erhöht natürlich das
risiko dass er andere ansteckt bitte
bleiben sie zu hause wenn sie krank sind
und von den befragten wissen 89 prozent
dass man sich bei symptomen in selbst
quarantäne begeben soll aber lediglich
63 prozent würden es tun
das ist nicht gut ja bitte verstehen sie
das dass das wirklich sinnvolle
maßnahmen sind die dazu beitragen die
krankheit einzudämmen also die die erste
säule unserer strategie bedienen und auf
der säule die ist auch sehr wichtig dass
zu den heutigen lagebericht danke ich
steht für ihre fragen zur verfügung
vielen dank die fragen sind wie immer
per e mail bis heute morgen um acht uhr
eingegangen und die arbeiten wir jetzt
auch ab das zdf fragt das öffentliche
interesse an corona dem zustand ab zumal
wenn wir erst am anfang der epidemie
stehen sie hingegen reduzieren die zahl
der pressekonferenzen und die frage
möglichkeiten wie können sie das in
dieser krise rechtfertigen
ja zum einen ist es so dass wir
natürlich wirklich neuigkeiten wirklich
durchbrüche nicht im täglichen rhythmus
haben das ist so und das wird auch so
bleiben sie können mir glauben wenn es
wirklich neue durchbrüche gibt in der
bekämpfungsstrategie und erfolge dann
werden natürlich auch extra termine
einbauen
wichtig ist mir zu sagen wir haben
inzwischen ja zwei medien wo wir sehr
aktuell immer über die tatsächlichen
lage berichten das eine ist das
dashboard
das wird meines wissens auch nach dieser
pressebriefing nochmals eingespielt und
das anders der täglichen lagebericht wir
informieren ja sehr sehr transparent
über die zahlen über die entwicklung und
ich denke dort können sich die
mitbürgerinnen mitbürger sehr sehr gut
informieren jeden tag aktualisiert
reuters fragt vor gut einer woche haben
sie von einem leichten optimismus
bezüglich einer abflachung der
infizierten vorgesprochen hat sich
dieser optimismus bestätigt
naja mein optimismus ist natürlich noch
immer da und ich denke es auch begründet
wir werden uns die zahlen anschauen
lassen sie uns warten bis wir wirklich
handfeste zahlen haben und das wird ich
gehe davon aus dass wir das bis ostern
sehen werden wie der trend ist aber das
hat mit meinem optimismus eigentlich
nichts zu tun da ist begründet und ich
gehe davon aus dass er auch begründet
sachlich sein wird sda/reuters fragt
auch liegt die einschätzung einer
sterblichkeit der infizierten in
deutschland weiter bei 1,2 prozent
also die sterblichkeitsrate ist momentan
nach unserem letzten situationsbericht
er ja auch im internet allen zur
verfügung steht meiner kenntnis bei 0,8
prozent
er ist nach wie vor die sterberate unter
den gemeldeten fällen in deutschland ist
gering
den grund dafür sehen wir darin dass wir
früh getestet haben dass wir viel testen
dass wir ja eben auch viele leichte
fälle in unserer testung haben und
dadurch ist die sterberate aktuellen
aber auch wieder mal ein hinweis die
meldungen die wir haben haben wir ein
zeitverzug
und natürlich werden menschen zuerst
infiziert gemeldet und die menschen
sterben ja dann erst später nach einem
gewissen krankheitsverlauf ich gehe also
davon aus nach wie vor dass die
sterberaten steigen werden und ein
weiter grund dadurch dass wir so früh
getestet haben und dadurch uns zu gut
vorbereiten konnten auch haben wir auch
viele leichte fälle einfach in der
testung drin
das heißt die schweren fälle und gesunde
leute also schöne junge und normale
gesunde population haben wir viel bei
den fällen
das heißt die alten und hochaltrigen die
wurden am anfang von uns nicht so
erfasst
wir haben jetzt ja auch leider fälle in
pflegeheimen in altenheimen und wir
müssen leider davon ausgehen dass die
sterberate damit auch ansteigen wird
rtl fragt wie beurteilt das erklärende
mundschutz pflicht österreich hat sich
für supermärkte eingeführt und die stadt
jena will sie für jeden in der
öffentlichkeit was bringt das aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht ja ich denke es
sind zwei dinge zu beachten
oft wird in der öffentlichkeit zwischen
dem sogenannten mund nasen schutz und
einer maske die einen bestimmten
sicherheitsniveau hat nicht
unterschieden das ist schade aber das
ist natürlich schwierig für
nichtfachleute zu unterscheiden die
sogenannten ffp zwei masten also masken
die wirklich viren abhalten das ist
masken die natürlich vor allem das
personal das medizinische personal und
das pflegepersonal das kranke menschen
pflegt tragen muss um sich optimal zu
schützen vor einer infektion
das ist ganz klar das steht im
vordergrund und das da müssen masken
genutzt werden der mund nasen schutz
dient und auch das ist stand des wissens
den mund nasen schutz dient dem schutz
anderer vor einer infektion also wenn
jemand selber infiziert ist dann ist es
klar dass ein mund nasenschutz dazu
führt dass wenn man hustet oder niest
die tröpfchen nicht so weit fliegen
können bildlich gesprochen und dann
schützt man den gegenüber
das ist sinnvoll und das empfehlen wir
seit anfang an und das empfehlen wir
natürlich auch weiterhin die ph audio
fragt würden selbst genähte masken
ausreichen
naja also da geht es wieder um die frage
masken oder mund nasenschutz aus meiner
sicht ist das ein mund nasen schutz
ich kann nicht beantworten was das das
hängt vom material ab welches material
verwendet wird klar ist folgendes auch
ein selbst gebauter mund nasen schutz
hält natürlich tröpfcheninfektion zurück
tröpfchen zurück wenn man niest und
hustet insofern ist er für den schutz
von anderen sicher von relevanz die
tagesschau fragt wie steht das lka zu
der forderung schnell und massenhafte
corona tests durchzuführen das virus
einzudämmen
wir fordern ja kontinuierlich dass die
test kapazitäten erhöht werden wir haben
in deutschland wirklich sehr sehr hohe
test kapazitäten das ist gut und richtig
und wichtig aber getestet werden müssen
leute nach bestimmten kriterien das ist
wichtig da gibt es zum einen das
kriterium dass wir eben kranke personen
haben wo es darum geht und differenzial
diagnostische ausschlussverfahren sind
die person infiziert mit irgendeiner
anderen pneumonie eine virale bono mini
oder bakterielle oder sind sie infiziert
mit kofi das ist der klassische
ärztliche differenzial diagnostische
anteil der andere teil wo menschen
geprüft wird getestet werden müssen ist
ja wenn es um diese kontakt
nachverfolgen geht also wir haben ein
ausbruch oder wir haben eine infizierte
person
und dann kommt das gesundheitsamt
untersucht wer sich vielleicht
angesteckt haben könnte und dann muss
man im rahmen dieser nachverfolgt
natürlich personen testen und es gibt
einen anderen aspekt noch wenn man im
krankenhaus zum beispiel frei getestet
wird bei personal das sind die
integration wofür wir testungen brauchen
die testungen müssen strategisch
sinnvoll
im rahmen dieser drei säulen unserer
strategie eingesetzt werden
vielleicht noch als kommentar das ist
nicht missverstanden wird die kontakte
bei der nachverfolgung natürlich dann
wenn die leute erkranken
das ist im tun bekommen danke für die
ergänzung wird die tagesschau fragt auch
noch in südkorea werden mit dem
sogenannten tracing kontakt und
infektionsketten lückenlos nachverfolgt
ist das in deutschland auch möglich also
sie müssen sich vorstellen dass die
arbeit der gesundheitsämter natürlich
sehr
das ist eine intensive arbeit da ist
jede technische hilfe willkommen
jede kontaktperson je schneller die
identifiziert wird desto schneller kann
natürlich auch die charaktere greifen
und so weiter
aber es gibt in deutschland keinerlei
aktivitäten dass man solche tools in
südkorea also uhrzeit ort messungen die
den standort von menschen nachvollziehen
kann
das ist sicher bei uns nicht angedacht
klar ist dass es in südkorea zur
beschleunigung der eindämmung von
ausbrüchen geführt hat
und da durch die gesundheitsämter
natürlich massiv geholfen hat dpa fragt
wie werden todesfälle in deutschland
erfasst wird nur erfasst wer
nachweislich und corona gestorben ist
wie sie sich das überhaupt realisieren
da nicht nach dem tod getestet wird wird
dadurch der eine oder andere corona fall
wiederum nicht erfasst also wir haben
bislang keinen hinweis das ist eine
große und erfassung an kopitz 19 fällen
gibt die testung gibt es die patienten
werden positiv getestet und dann kennt
eben der krankheits ablauf davon ab ob
sie die krankheit überstehen
ob es eine milde krankheit ist eine
schwere und ob sie sie überleben oder
nicht wir haben keinerlei hinweis dass
für eine große und erfassung von kogit
19 verstorbenen patienten haben in
deutschland dpa fragt auch an corona
erfasst zunimmt alten und pflegeheime
werden wir nun einen raschen anstieg der
sterberate in deutschland sehen ja ich
hatte das eben schon angesprochen
wir müssen diese gruppen besonders
schützen klar ist wenn ausbrüche in
solchen pflegeheim und altenheim
wirklich auftreten dann sterben dann ist
eben die chance dass die personen die
infiziert werden schwer erkrankt bzw
sterben deutlich höher als bei der
gesunden und jungen gruppe also die
sterberaten werden dann zu nehmen ja
jetzt geht es in die ganz andere
richtung bild fragt was sagen sie
schwangere und frauen die in ein oder
zwei wochen kinder auf die welt bringen
naja die sollen sich natürlich vor
infektionen schützen das ist ganz klar
schwangere sollen sich immer vor
infektionen schützen stärker vielleicht
noch noch mehr aufpassen also die die
regeln um die wir sie bitten ganz klar
einzuhalten wir wissen bislang aber
nicht es gibt keinen hinweis dass
schwangere besonders stärker gefährdet
werden mit diesem virus infiziert zu
werden also dass dieses virus besonders
die frucht beeinträchtigt wie das bei
anderen virusinfektionen der fall ist
also sie sollen sie schützen und
natürlich versuchen alles dafür zu tun
dass sie nicht infiziert werden
der wdr fragt sagt thema hatten wir eben
auch schon mal kurz wie hilfreich wäre
es zum finden von kontaktpersonen wenn
man über die handys auf bewegungsdaten
der bürger zurückgreifen könnte wäre die
herausgabe der daten freiwillig wie
viele prozent müssten mitmachen damit es
sinnvoll wäre
wie gesagt es wurde tatsächlich dass das
contact racing wurde beschleunigt das
heißt die arbeit der gesundheitsämter
wurde beschleunigt aber im idealfall
müssten da natürlich alle menschen alle
mitbürger mitbürgerinnen so etwas haben
aber ich sag noch mal diese ortszeit
messung als methode ist in deutschland
definitiv datenschutzrechtlich nicht
möglich ich sehe hier keine
umsetzungsmöglichkeit der wdr fragt auch
wie stark können die kapazitäten für
tests auf das virus noch gesteigert
werden
das ist eine frage die ist nicht leicht
zu beantworten also wir hatten ja in der
letzten woche wenn ich das richtig in
erinnerung habe
rund 350.000 tests also viel mehr ist da
sicher nicht drin momentan aber wir
reden zurzeit nur über diese pcr tests
das heißt also den nachweis des erbgutes
in bestimmten material und in der
zukunft kommen bestimmt auch andere
tests dazu die auch einfacher sind und
dann kann man die test kapazität sicher
noch steigern ich vermag aber nicht zu
sagen wie viel und das wird vor allem
davon abhängen ob man wirklich eine gute
logistik aufbaut also eine zentrale
erfassung von tests und dann logistisch
diese tests sehr gut einsetzt dass
ausrollt in die einzelnen praxen und
hospitäler
also da ist noch luft nach oben aber wie
viel das ist das vermag ich wirklich
nicht einzuschätzen
die riff reporter fragen gibt es zahlen
darüber wie sich die
überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit bei
schwerkranken mit und ohne
intensivmedizinische behandlung
unterscheidet oder das weiß ich nicht
das kann ich nicht sagen aber klar ist
natürlich dass die
überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit massiv
steigt wenn man geordnet werden kann das
ist glaube ich kann dazu keine zahlen
habe ich keinen kopf gibt es hierzulande
erkenntnisse und gegebenfalls fallzahlen
zu patienten bei denen nicht in erster
linie die lungenfunktion beeinträchtigt
ist sondern das herz durch das virus
geschädigt wird fragt ebenfalls
rösrather mir sind solche zahlen nicht
bekannt ich weiß allerdings von
italienischen kollegen
das rund 25 prozent ich bin jetzt nicht
sicher ob es die verstorben sind oder
auf einen fall
es gibt tatsächlich bei vielen personen
herzmuskelentzündungen und das hat für
das outcome der erkrankungen natürlich
eine große bedeutung
es sieht also so aus als werden dieses
virus auch eine infektion der
herzmuskeln hervorruft dts
nachrichtenagentur halle fragt besteht
eine wahrscheinlichkeit dass die aktuell
in deutschland eingeleiteten maßnahmen
auch die verbreitung von anderen
infektionskrankheiten wie grippe oder
tuberkulose eindämmen
also das abstandsgebot und alle die
maßnahmen der der physischen
distanzierung die wir wünschen wird auch
eine wird auch einfluss darauf haben wie
sich das grippe virus weiter verbreitet
sicher wir sind allerdings schon sehr
sehr abgeflacht also die grippewelle
neigt sich dem ende
schwer zu sagen welche effekte wie
gewirkt haben aber auf die grippe
übertragen hat er sich auch einen
positiven effekt radio farbenspiel fragt
erklärtes ziel von medizinern politik
ist es immer wieder den anstieg der
fallzahlen zu verlangsamen und damit die
bekannte kurve zu drücken um das
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
wären bei einem funktionierenden
gesundheitssystems die aktuell geltenden
maßnahmen ebenfalls verhältnismäßig
anders gefragt gelten die aktuell
getroffenen maßnahmen primär dem schutz
eines mangelhaften gesundheitssystems
also die frage kann ich nicht ganz
verstehen
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass wir in
deutschland sehr sehr viele kapazitäten
haben und sehr sehr viele intensivbetten
pro kopf und wir erhöhen dass er sogar
also es geht wirklich darum dass wir das
gesundheitssystem maximal dazu nutzen
menschenleben zu retten ich behaupte mal
und das müssen wir noch mal genau
nachrichten
das ist eigentlich kein anderes land auf
der welt gibt was mehr beatmungs plätze
pro kopf einwohner hat als deutschland
also insofern haben wir diesbezüglich
ein wirklich sehr leistungsfähiges
gesundheitssystem
ja ja die aufgabe ist einfach das
optimal zu nutzen
logistisch zu nutzen also
patienten optimal zu den dann
aufgebauten kapazitäten zu ziehen das
war der punkt den ich anspruch mit dem
register der dv also das ist wichtig wir
müssen patienten optimal zu führen ob
das ausreicht ob wir genug betten dann
haben werden im falle dieser wirklich
sehr sehr umfänglichen epidemie ist ist
eine andere frage
ja dann sind wir am ende angekommen dann
bedanken wir uns
wir werden gerade gefragt noch von einer
anwesenden journalisten etwas zu
antikörpertest zu sagen also antikörper
tests weisen nach ob eine person schon
mit dem virus infiziert gewesen ist also
wenn man zum beispiel die infektion
überstanden hat oder wenn man sie noch
in der infektions phase ist die
krankheit doch auch noch nicht abgeflaut
ist das sind wichtige tests diese tests
dienen dazu zu sehen wie hoch die
dunkelziffer ist zum beispiel population
also es gibt ja also es wird eine
bestimmte anteil von menschen die
infiziert werden werden ja gar nicht
krank wir sagen immer von denen die
krank werden wenn etwa vier von fünf
werden nur leicht krank einer von fünf
schwer erkannt und durch die antikörper
test können wir eine aussage darüber
machen wie viele schon infiziert wohn
und die krankheit überstanden
wir können auch einen gewissen einblick
gewinnen
ob diese person immun sind oder nicht
man weiß ja bislang noch nicht wie lange
die immunität hält das dauert auch noch
eine weile bis man das wirklich handfest
sagen kann
dafür sind diese antikörper test gut und
es werden verschiedene studien geplant
in deutschland sind auch schon einige
werden durchgeführt aber die güte hängt
sehr stark von der qualität der tests ab
die verwendet werden sofern darf man
nicht hast dich jetzt irgendwelche tests
verwenden nur um eine studie zu machen
sondern die tests müssen eine hohe
qualität haben und dann können wir
darüber eine aussage treffen
vielleicht nur zur klarstellung sind
eigentlich keine journalisten im raum ab
sonst ist nur eine dame als begleitung
für ein kamerateam dabei und deswegen
war das auch eine ausnahme
sodann bedanken uns ganz herzlich fürs
zuhören oder zuschauen und bis freitag